so today's video is sponsored by the bay
also known as bae systems which is
definitely what you were thinking they
do lots of things like building boats
and airplanes and submarines so perfect
fit for me really when you think charlie
is so cool like you think submarines
don't you it make sense well actually
they also do a roadshow here in the UK
where they tour schools and try and
inspire a love of science in kids as
part of that they have a bunch of cool
experiments that they do on stage and
they have been nice enough to lend me
some of their experiments so I can play
around with them and show them to you so
yeah let's get experimenting all right
there hello what we have here is Bell
and it's in a bell jar the jar looks
like a bell and that's why it's called a
bell jar but it just also happens to
have a bell in sight here you don't
always have to put a bell in a bell jar
you know you can put whatever you want
in whatever you want as long as it's
consensual and this turns on doesn't it
there you go that's the sound of a bell
it's quite annoying isn't it Gideon yes
it is Gideon - my cat just in case
you're not aware of the full context so
you can hear that relatively well while
it's underneath the bell jar but what
this experiment is designed to show you
is that sound only can travel through
air which is what this thing is for this
is a vacuum like a way less efficient
version of my vacuum cleaner so we're
gonna do is going to try and use this to
take the air out there and we'll see
what happens to the sound of the Bell
attaching it there see you can't hear
the bell because all you can hear is
this thing now let's just wait a while
for the air to come out of that jar and
then we'll check back in
see now really all I can hear is this
it's this thing let's turn that off for
a moment you can still hear it probably
because there's a gap in the bell jar
somewhere but if we let the air back in
still annoying alright that one did work
perfectly but hopefully it gave you an
idea of what was going on try another
shall we oh wow oh God
so a little bit less high-tech than the
last one but still very cool to promise
before I show you before your very eyes
how I could make this glass stick turn
invisible first we need to talk a little
bit about refraction
everyone loves refraction so what this
is is when light travels through a
specific substance like glass or water
that light is slowed down a little bit
and it causes the light to bend this is
why when I put this little glass stick
inside of this bowl of water it kind of
looks like it's coming into the wrong
angle and looks a bit bent at the bottom
and that is because of how the glass and
the water are bending the light however
what might happen if we were to put
glass inside a slightly different
substance like glycerin really thought
that was gonna ding then why is enough
there's another experiment to be done
there isn't now glycerin is really
annoying and sticky but the interesting
thing about it is it has the same
refractive index as glass which means it
slows down light at the same speed the
glass does and makes it Bend in exactly
the same way well pretty much exactly
it's exact enough anyway that if I am to
put this glass stick inside of the
glycerin you can see that it does what
you can't see it I mean you can say if
you look if you'll meet and if you like
this and you're looking really closely
then you can vaguely see it but you
aren't gonna be able to say anything I
see I just explained it and I'm already
just like how the hell does that work
that's refractive indexes for you okay
last experiments
so what I have here is some sand a
little metallic plate which is attached
to this machine which will create any
frequency I want it to so so pretty
annoying isn't it so what I need to do
is I need to just put a little
sprinkling of sand onto the plate season
the plates and then there are some
specific frequencies I can hit with this
that will make that send turn into a
lovely pattern which will let us
visualize sound I just have to find out
what those frequencies are Gideon is
well pissed off at me right now they can
need more sand heavily season looking at
one Oh someone's moving let's get some
more sand on there there's something
happening there quite as impressive as I
was hoping
god that is so annoying Oh oh my go
ahead did it look at that what are we
actually seeing here well this is the
sound that's coming out of the center is
causing this this shape is pattern so
the higher we go the more intricate
these patterns will get come on show me
show me this good stuff I believe oh
there it is there's what people right
I'm definitely going to start that one
there because good lord that hurts I
hope you enjoyed that I don't know if
you really learn anything by a hell of a
lot of fun especially with this one and
I say for today
see ya good play you've just had the
almost imponderable joy of watching
Charlie is so cool like which makes you
like cool thank you very much for
watching if you haven't heard I am
writing fun science book at the moment
and I talked about that in my last video
which you can find there and if you've
been missing me generally then I will
throw you once again to my other youtube
channel cereal time where you can see me
mess around with my friend Jimmy let me
know as well if you enjoyed seeing me
doing fun science experiments for a
change cuz it really is a new thing for
me but if you dig it
I will do more I'll find a way that's
all thanks again for watching and good
not by just good good